d'accord il recouvre le même couteau à
part les autoroutes soit libéré ne
tourne pas moi ça arrive et on a tablé
femme de votre vie si pour lui si magna
cum indépendamment pourquoi matoury ils
ont pas mieux que le meilleur liban qui
ont tourné donc c'est bien une jeune
maman mais comme il ya une pizza qui
constate une bonne tenue
[Musique]
bon des fois on voit les grands
bêtisiers pas les cailloux qui blessent
les l'écueil qui blessent les gens j'ai
fait ça tape les yeux de poids le matou
lampe de poche à sosa tape légèrement
visage qu'il ya beaucoup d'accidents et
j'ai pas même vous voyez même la
deuxième c'est glissant ça se bosse
beaucoup
[Musique]